we are living in a difficult period
experiencing a war in europe
this ruthless and unprovoked invasion of
ukraine by russia is different to the
pandemic and the nature and climate
crisis we are facing
yet there is so much in common
once again we are called to rethink the
foundation of our economy of our energy
and production systems
we think how should we
use best the resources we need and the
resources we have
more than ever we need a new approach to
the way we design make and use products
our new initiative on eco design aims to
set the bar high and make sustainable
products the norm
it's a real game changer
products
our
mobile phones tvs
laptops textiles should not only be
energy efficient
but also made to last
and we should never lose the materials
they contain
those valuable resources should keep on
circulating in our economy making it
more resilient to shocks
we can make our products more durable
more usable easier to upgrade repair and
refurbish and we can make them have a
lighter footprint on nature and climate
change
and this is the way i had to change how
we treat our planet
[Music]
i look forward to making this change
happen together